[MUSIC PLAYING]
YOSHI TAMURA: Good morning.
Thanks for coming.
We're going to talk about
GKE Sandbox for multi-tenancy
and security in this session.
How many people went to
the party last night?
Oh, quite a bit.
Thank you for coming after
playing around at the party.
I kind of missed it.
But we have a lot to cover
today, so let's get started.
So first, we should
introduce ourselves.
Tim, you want to go first?
TIM KELTON: Sure, thanks.
My name's Tim Kelton,
and I'm the co-founder
of Descartes Labs.
And I work on building tools to
model and understand the earth.
And the other part
of my job is doing
all of our cloud architecture
and our SRE and security teams.
YOSHI TAMURA: All
right, thanks, Tim.
So then my turn.
So hi, I'm Yoshi.
I'm product manager
on Kubernetes Engine.
I work on gVisor, multi-tenancy,
and [? machining ?] stuff,
like GPU and Cloud
Compute in GKE.
Next, Ian.
IAN LEWIS: I'm Ian Lewis.
I'm a developer advocate.
I focus on GKE and
container security.
YOSHI TAMURA: Cool.
Sorry.
Let's then begin.
But before we begin, we would
like to know about you as well.
So let me ask this question.
So how many of you think
yourself as like an application
developer or a DevOps or SRE?
Oh, many-- I'll say
like 80% of people, OK?
And then how many of you think
a security engineer [INAUDIBLE]??
Interesting.
Like 10% or 20%, I think.
OK, how many of you
actually wear both hats
at the same time?
There you go.
My customer Tim here.
OK, that's interesting.
So the reason I
ask this question
comes from my experience
meeting with users,
customers like yourself.
I feel lucky that I can have
an interaction with you all
the time.
And one thing I realize is
that there are two sides when
I go to these kind of meetings.
One side is like developers,
application developers, DevOps,
SREs, who really care about
speed and flexibility.
Of course, those people who
like containers and Kubernetes.
And the other side, security
folks who, of course,
deeply care about
security, apparently.
And as you can
imagine, I frequently
kind of feel that there are some
challenges between these two
groups when it comes down to
making important engineering
and architecture
decisions, for example,
container or not, Kubernetes or
not, sharing Kubernetes or not,
[INAUDIBLE] clusters or not.
So let's see where this kind
of a challenge is coming from.
We believe that's because,
fundamentally, containers
do not contain.
We've been saying this,
actually, from last year,
but this means that while
containers are really, really
great for speed and flexibility
to increase your productivity,
it's actually not in
a security isolation
boundary for your workloads.
That means that many--
like a lot of you in this
room, the security folks,
or who are wearing both hats--
have to harden the
containers end to end.
And that can mean a lot of work.
You can certainly harden your
containers through policies
and do the right thing.
However, technically maintaining
this or doing this right
could be very, very
challenging sometimes.
We all know that
security is critical.
And it's also true
that we have a lot
of things to keep in mind.
So there is a
constant demand-- when
I go to customer
meetings-- there's
a constant demand
about security that,
can't we just do it
in just one click?
There's isn't an easy way.
That's just totally,
totally understandable.
In fact, open source
software is growing.
Everyone, I'm pretty sure, is
using some kind of open source.
And that's really cool.
A lot of features come in
and it reflects users voices
very quickly.
But when it comes
down to actually using
production, using
it on your own,
it is actually your
responsibility.
You have to meet--
mostly security team
has to actually be in charge
of assuring its integrity.
Also on top of that,
the vulnerabilities
around containers keep coming
up, which I'll dig deeper.
Most recently, there was a
runC container escape in runC.
How many people
heard about this?
Oh, yeah.
This one's, actually, kind
of [? Wiley ?] mentioned.
So it's pretty understandable.
So just to explain
a little bit more--
runC is the engine of
the container runtime,
like Docker container,
Containerd, and cri-o.
And in this case, if
the attacker's process
was running as root
inside a container,
the attacker was able to gain
the root access of the host
by overriding your runC
binary from inside.
An obvious way to
mitigate this threat
was to run the container
as a non-root, of course.
And apparently,
this is definitely
the recommended way of
running your containers
in the first place.
However, now, even if you
did run your containers
as non-root, you still need
to think about the container
escape through the Linux kernel.
So not many people
know about this,
but the Linux kernel has
a huge attack surface.
And this type of
container escape
can happen by exploiting the
bugs inside the Linux kernel.
And if the attack
was successful,
the attacker may be able to
bypass the container mechanism
or elevate its privilege.
One of the most well-known
cases of this is Dirty COW.
This is a privilege escalation
using a bug in the Linux kernel
by exploiting a race condition
in the copy-on-write system,
COW, in the memory system--
in the memory subsystem.
The non-local user was able
to increase their privileges
on the system.
So again, containers
do not contain.
Thus, you would definitely want
to think about running only
trusted code in your system.
Now, if your system were
running trusted code,
you're following the right best
practice and lower privilege,
that's really great.
However, in case of
SaaS and multi-tenancy,
things don't necessarily
work that way.
If you're running a SaaS,
like Tim, my customer,
your customers will be--
would like to upload their code
to run their favorite plugins
on your service.
Like in case of, for example,
in our Google Service,
like Cloud Run could be a
good example that we launch.
If you have your functions or
code in service containers,
your cluster users will
be uploading whatever code
they want to to your system.
And you, as a service
provider, want
to share a cluster
to save the cost.
As a consequence,
basically, an untrusted code
can be running on the
shared cluster by default.
Now, therefore, we
need a solution.
And there's a good news.
There are containers
actually do contain,
and they are called sandbox.
Sandbox is a hot
topic in Kubernetes.
In fact, there are a number of
sandbox technologies emerged
in open source in just
the last year and a half.
And also, in the
Kubernetes world,
Kubernetes Runtime
Class was added
to provide an API to access to
this to sandbox your containers
together with the new
technologies that's
happening in open source world.
Now, open source
technologies are coming up.
And now the question is, do
we have the product for that?
With that, we're very excited
to introduce the GKE Sandbox
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
As the name says,
it provides sandbox,
containers do contain, to
GKE as defense-in-depth
at the pod level.
It is based on
open source gVisor,
which is what Google invented.
And then also widely used
in the Google internally.
Now, since we open
sourced gVisor,
you might have heard about
Google products that's
using gVisor.
The most recent one
is the Cloud Run
that we announced at Next, at
the keynote on the first day.
And one of the reasons that
gVisor, powering GKE Sandbox,
got so popular at Google
is that it does not require
any application changes.
If you have your workloads,
you have your containers,
you don't necessarily
have to change
to get your stuff sandboxed.
So if you're thinking
about how to use this,
you don't have to
actually think about it.
You just have to
turn it on and then
run your pods on GKE Sandbox.
So how can GKE Sandbox help you?
GKE Sandbox can help you by--
it's really easy to use.
It has defense-in-depth
without hassling.
First of all, it's part of GKE.
The Google Kubernetes Engine is
a managed Kubernetes service.
This GKE Sandbox is fully
integrated into GKE.
Thus, you don't have
to install anything.
You don't have to install
open source gVisor.
We already baked in everything.
And we made a toggle in
the switch very simple
that we're going to talk deeper.
So if you have a container,
if you're already on GKE,
you just couple switch,
and there you go.
In addition to that, I
just kind of mentioned,
the technology is behind
the scene is gVisor.
And like I mentioned,
you don't have
to change your application.
You don't have to
change your applications
or not know a new
mental model to use it.
You just run it as if
you run your regular--
your pods regularly.
Second, it limits
the potential attacks
by reducing attack surface.
Today, the container and
the host operating system
are tied together.
What GKE Sandbox
provides are two layers
of isolation in between.
Like this.
I can't actually hold it.
But the first layer of isolation
is the user [? line ?] kernel
written in Go that
gVisor provides.
And then even if that
gets compromised,
there is additional filter,
seccomp and namespace,
that would actually
prevent further attack.
So from here, sitting together,
to two layers in between.
We're going to dig deeper
on this one as well.
Third, GKE Sandbox
can help teams
who want to run SaaS
and multi-tenancy,
because it provides the
strong isolation boundaries.
For example, like Cloud Run
that got announced again,
is using gVisor, the same
technology behind GKE Sandbox.
When you have such untrusted
code coming here and there
all the time, you
do need isolation.
Therefore, you want to think
about this kind of technology
sandbox to be used
in your system.
So I think GKE Sandbox should
be a great fit for those
who are planning to
go in multi-tenancy
or who have SaaS
similar to Cloud
Run, and many further services.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over to Ian
to talk more about the
technology backing up
GKE Sandbox, which is gVisor
that is already in open source.
Ian.
IAN LEWIS: OK, so I'm going to
be talking about gVisor, which
is the open source
project that is
what is used behind the
scenes by GKE Sandbox.
So gVisor is an open source
project, container sandbox
runtime.
And what that is is it's an
OCI runtime, much like runC,
if you're familiar with that.
It's used extensively at Google
for a number of different use
cases.
But as Yoshi
mentioned, for Cloud,
it's used for certain products
that run untrusted code,
for things like Cloud Run, and
our new App Engine runtimes.
As an open source project,
it's available on GitHub.
And we have a lot
of documentation
available at gVisor.dev.
So if you're interested
in the project,
definitely check
out the website.
We have lots of documentation on
the architecture, the security
model, and lots more.
And we'll also be--
we have mailing lists and a
community meeting next week.
So if you're
interested in getting
involved with the project,
definitely checking it out.
All of that information
is on the community page
on the website.
So to give some
background into gVisor,
and why we developed it,
and the thinking behind it,
we wanted to be able to run
untrusted code on behalf
of users.
But at Google, we
use containers a lot
as part of our infrastructure.
And typically, the way that you
would build a sandbox like this
is you would use some
sort of hardware isolation
mechanism, like a VM, or
a Virtual Machine Manager.
But that doesn't
really necessarily fit
with our architecture
in a way that we liked.
And we wanted it to be
much more container-like,
and for it to be something
that really was very resource
efficient at scale.
So we obviously need
something that provides us
that defense-in-depth, that
extra layer of isolation,
but gave us a lightweight
way of running a container.
We wanted something that
was very low overhead,
something that was able to
start and stop containers
very quickly and easily.
But we also wanted something
that was zero configuration.
So if you're not using
a VMM, then usually you
would do something like using
AppArmor or seccomp, which
tend to be based on
configuration or filtering,
and they depend a lot on
how the application behaves.
So you typically
filter out the things
that the application
doesn't need to do.
But you need to manage that
configuration over time
as the application changes.
And it's very important
from a security standpoint
that you keep that
configuration correct.
Like if your application
starts doing less things,
you need to then update it so
that the filter includes those
things and it doesn't--
it's very hard from a security
standpoint to make sure
that all of the applications
that you're deploying
are managed correctly.
And we also wanted to be able
to run binaries unmodified.
We didn't want to have to
update our applications
with a new library,
or link to a new thing
in order to get the
applications to run.
We wanted to just be able to
run regular applications that
were built for Linux.
So we built gVisor in order
to solve those problems.
And what gVisor does is
it provides a user space
kernel that is run in user
space with your container.
And as it runs your container,
or your container application,
it intercepts the system calls
that your application makes
and handles those in user space.
So in that sense, it's
very similar to something
like user space Linux, but
it's a totally new kernel
that's implemented in
Go using the Go runtime.
And we chose Go because
it's a very good runtime.
It provides a lot of things,
like garbage collection,
as well as type
safety, so things
that they can help with the
security of the user space
kernel itself.
And each pod is isolated with
its own user space kernel.
So we don't have a
single user space
kernel for all containers.
And this keeps all of
the containers isolated
from each other.
But by having this
user space kernel,
we're also isolating
from the host,
so that the host interaction
is greatly reduced.
And so we don't have containers
interacting with the host
and able to get host
level privileges.
So diving a little bit
deeper into the architecture
for gVisor, gVisor provides
an OCI runtime interface.
So this is-- the OCI is the
Open Containers Initiative.
And this is a standard
for running containers.
And so we provide
an OCI interface
in the form of an
application called runsc.
And this is a single binary that
you can use to deploy gVisor
and install it.
And so it's basically
a drop-in replacement
for the runC binary.
And when you run
the container, we
start up the container
in the user space
with our user space kernel.
And we call this the sentry.
And then when the
container runs,
we use something called
a platform in order
to intercept the system
calls and reroute,
direct those into the sentry.
And we use KVM and ptrace
as our two platforms
that we provide as part of
the open source project.
And then on top of
the sandbox itself, we
have the sandbox held inside
of a container, a normal host
container which is using
seccomp and namespaces
in order to further
isolate from the host.
So as Yoshi mentioned, we
have two isolation layers.
One is the sentry itself
in the user space kernel,
and the second is
the host itself
and the seccomp and namespaces
that the host provides.
And so in order to get
control of the entire host,
you would need to break
through both of those isolation
boundaries.
In order to further
add isolation,
we have something
called a gopher, which
is a separate process
that gets run when
you run the runsc container.
And that provides file
I/O. So the sentry
itself does not have permission
to open files on the local file
system.
So even if you get
control of the sentry,
you're not able to write
to the host file system
and gain extra
privileges that way.
You have to go through
a separate process that
is over 9P in order to
write files and deal
with file I/O. This gives us
an extra layer, because there's
a lot of different types
of attack services,
and gives us that extra
two levels of isolation
for file I/O as well.
So that's gVisor itself.
How does that fit into
GKE Sandbox and GKE?
So with GKE, we provide a
managed control plane, an API
server, and then each of
the nodes in the cluster
is a GCE VM.
And you can arrange
those in node pools.
So a node pool is a group
of servers in your cluster
or worker nodes in
your cluster that
have the same configurations,
the same machine
type, and things like that.
And you can have multiple
node pools in your cluster.
And so what GKE Sandbox
allows you to do
is create node pools
that have gVisor enabled.
So basically, add an extra
checkbox in the cloud console
or an extra flag on G
Cloud enables you to create
a gVisor enabled node pool.
And then when you
run your nodes,
or you run your
workloads in the cluster
and you specify gVisor as the
runtime, then you can run--
it will schedule and
run your workloads
on your gVisor node pool.
So let's drill down
into one of these nodes.
Each of these nodes has an
agent, the Kubernetes agent,
the Kubelet.
And that Kubelet is responsible
for running the workloads
on that VM or that worker node.
And in order to
run containers that
uses an extra runtime,
in this case, Containerd,
which is high level
runtime, and that in turn
uses OCI to use a low
level runtime in order
to run containers.
So typically, this would
be done using runC.
But what we can do with our
gVisor enabled pod, or nodes,
is to swap that out for gVisor.
And this is enabled
because we're using the OCI
as a standard interface.
So how do you use it from
a user's perspective?
So from a user's perspective,
all you need to do
is specify the runtime class
name as part of your pod spec.
Kubernetes provides what's
called a RuntimeClass
API, which is a
new API that allows
you to find different
runtimes that you
can use within your cluster.
And GKE Sandbox provides
this automatically
when you create a node pool
that is gVisor enabled.
So you don't have to
worry, necessarily,
about creating these runtime
classes and managing those.
Those are more of a system
or a cluster administrator
type of a role.
But from a user's
perspective, or somebody
wanting to run
workloads, all you
need to do is put this
runtime class name of gVisor
into your pod spec, and
then that will get run
in gVisor when you submit
that to the API server.
So what kind of workloads
are good for gVisor
from a technical perspective?
So gVisor works really well
for things like microservices,
so things that are
very small and quick,
and needs to come up and
down, and are highly scalable,
as well as dense.
So things that can take
advantage of the low overhead
that gVisor provides work
really well in gVisor.
So if you're running
microservices
that make use of a lot
of third party code,
perhaps you're using
something like NodeJS
and you have a lot of external
libraries that you're using,
or pretty much any other
type of language, running
that in gVisor might be a way
of better ensuring that you have
some extra isolation there.
It's also really good for
SaaS and serverless workloads.
So things that you're going
to be running code on a user's
behalf.
So people upload some code and
you run it on their behalf.
Those type of things give you a
little bit of extra confidence
that you're not exposing
your entire infrastructure
to the code that gets uploaded.
It's also really good for batch
and machine learning workloads.
So gVisor, because it's
running as a user space kernel,
it's running
directly on the CPU.
And so CPU intensive workloads
work really well for it.
It also is really
good for applications
that run on this kind
of complex user input,
so user input that comes
into the application and gets
processed.
Typically for things like
machine learning and batch,
that data is user-submitted,
so things like uploaded images
or uploaded data.
And you typically
don't really want
to think about all the different
types of complex user input
that could come in, and whether
well-crafted input could
cause a security issue
with your application.
You'd like to be able to
just run it in a sandbox
and not have to think that
much about the security
implications.
So let's take a look at the
software as a service use case.
So I'm going to switch
over to a demo here.
So what I've built
here is I've built
an application
that is a WordPress
software as a service.
It's a very simple
service that allows
me to create a
WordPress instance
and run that WordPress
on behalf of my users.
But what I want to
do is I want to be
able to allow users to upload
or install any plugins that they
want to as part of their
WordPress application.
And those plugins can basically
contain arbitrary code, right?
So these are plugins that are
available on the WordPress
marketplace, and are
not really vetted
by me in terms of their
security and that sort of thing.
So what I want to do is
be able to allow people
to create their own
plugins, to install plugins
on the marketplace
without having
to worry too much about
the security implications.
So what I can do here is I
can create a new WordPress,
and call that Ian's blog.
And I can create
any number of these.
I'll create Yoshi's blog too.
And what this is
going to do, this
is implemented as a simple
controller in Kubernetes.
So this creates a CRD
that then gets kicked off
and creates some pods
for me in my cluster.
And so if I go over
here and I look
at the state of
the cluster, and we
see that I've got
to node pools here.
And this is a
listing of the nodes.
I first have my default
pool, which is just
a non-gVisor enabled node pool.
And then I have a
second node pool
that is enabling gVisor here.
And so if I go ahead
and get the pods that
are running in my
cluster, I can see
that I've started the
WordPress for my blog
and I've started the
WordPress for Yoshi's blog.
And we can see that the
WordPress blogs are running
in our gVisor node pool.
We can also see that
if we get the pod here,
we can see that our
runtime class name here
is specified as gVisor.
So that means that it's running
our workload inside of gVisor
itself.
Great.
All right, so our blogs
are up and running,
so let's go ahead and
click on our blog here.
And so what we'll have is we'll
have a brand new blog that's
running inside of gVisor.
And it's taking a little
bit to connect here.
Let's try Yoshi's blog.
All right.
So we go ahead
and click English.
Let's say the site's
title is Yoshi's blog.
Create that.
Hide this guy.
Go ahead install.
And log in to our new WordPress.
And so this is a fully
functioning WordPress site.
And so what we can do here is we
can go in and add new plugins.
So we can install basically
any plugin we want here,
like a classic editor, and
have that install and activate
without having to worry too
much about what that actually
contains in terms of the
code that's included in it.
So what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to actually upload a new
plugin that I want to install
that my friend Tim gave me.
And this one's called Dirty COW.
I'm not really
sure what's in it,
but I'm just going to go ahead
and install it, because he
said it's really cool.
So if I install this guy,
it installed successfully.
OK, so let's go ahead and
click on this Activate here.
When we do that, it
kind of sits here
and spins for a little while.
I don't know if
you can see this,
but it's sitting
here and spinning.
But if we go into our
logs, we can see that--
oh, it's not quite up yet.
But what this is doing
in the background
is it's actually running
the Dirty COW exploit as a--
all right, here we can see it.
So it's actually
running Dirty COW,
trying to attempt to take over
my WordPress installation.
So we can see here we're
running the Dirty COW exploit.
And what Dirty COW does is
it uses madvise and ptrace,
the system calls, and
running those in parallel
in order to try to take
advantage of the system
and take advantage of a
bug in the Linux kernel
in order to actually take
control of the whole system.
While this is kind
of an old bug,
and that most Linux systems
are patched nowadays,
this is just a good example
of the type of class of bugs
that gVisor can prevent,
and that it helps mitigate.
All right, so let's go back.
Let's go back to
the slides, yeah.
So next I want to
have Time come up
and talk about machine learning
and the use cases around that,
and what he's been doing.
TIM KELTON: Thanks, Ian.
You like my plug-in?
So I don't know if any of you
have heard of Descartes Labs,
but we're a startup that's a few
years old, about four years old
now.
And we're kind of focused on
the area of machine learning
and on being able to
better observe the earth.
And our background is, we're a
kind of stereotypical startup.
We're up in the mountains
of Santa Fe, New Mexico.
And we're there because
myself and the founding team
were out of Los Alamos
National Laboratory.
And there we were researchers
in high performance
supercomputing, astrophysics.
And among them, we did
research in things like machine
learning and being able to apply
that to remote sensing data.
And we do that because--
and we started the
company to basically
be able to understand
how changes happening all
over the world will start
to impact our customers
and their businesses,
their organizations,
and even their supply chain.
And I don't have to go
around and tell you there's
a proliferation of sensors.
All of you have phones,
and you know all about IoT
and things like that.
And that's on the ground.
But we're having that same
parallel explosion in sensor
technology happening in space.
And so we're getting better
and better resolution,
more and more modalities,
better temporal coverage.
And it's just getting
cheaper and cheaper.
These used to be half
billion dollar instruments
that NASA put up.
Now there's grad departments
that are making these.
And there's startups
here in the Bay
that are just launching them.
So what that's going
to do is that's going
to change how we can observe
and measure the earth.
And it's fundamentally changing
a lot of the workflows.
So a lot of the
datasets we leverage
are really scientific in nature.
They come from places like
NASA or European Space Agency.
But more and more, we're
just seeing that hit
on the commercial level.
And this new type of
workflow is totally
different than
historically what happened.
Historically, you
would have an analyst
and they would pull down an
image onto their desktop.
Well, that worked
great when you had
four scenes that were
captured once a month
and things like that.
But we've long passed when
the images and the data that
was being captured was
humanly observable.
And that's the type
of machine workflows
that we're trying to leverage.
So things like drought, and food
supply, and famine, and water--
precious commodities that
go into building everything
around us.
Those are what impacts us.
And so this is kind of this
new digital twin of the planet
that we're trying to
measure and understand.
And we have probably nearly
20 petabytes of data now
that's stored up in the
cloud that we run and iterate
on models.
So that's great.
We never could do that
before without the cloud.
But it does create
some challenges.
What we did was
originally make these APIs
for our own machine
learning team
so they could scale up and
test datasets, test models
against these huge datasets.
And when we run our--
so we built our SaaS platform,
obviously, on the cloud.
And often, it's not
just those datasets
that our customers want to use.
They want to build
their own models.
They want to often use one of
their pieces of data to get
new insights for their company.
So I thought I'd show
you some examples.
Warning, this is going
to be lots of pictures.
I hope that's OK.
It's Thursday.
So this is a solar
facility in Morocco.
It's pretty amazing to look at.
But often, it's
temporally how things
change that give
us those insights,
and we need to be
able to understand.
So obviously, this is the
construction and the building
of that facility.
Another example is
showing patterns of life.
Often we need to fuse
together different sensors,
and not just one.
So in the top row is just
normal red, green, and blue,
like all of us as
humans can see.
But the bottom row is
fusing together infrared.
And you'll notice on the
far bottom right, one
of the big things you can't see
with just human visible light
is that thermal signature.
We do this for all
different types of examples.
We're starting to now
run a wildfire detection
algorithm that will run over the
entire western half of the US.
We don't know exactly where
a wildfire might happen,
but being able to detect
those thermal signatures
is important.
This is another example.
This is more in the computer
vision and types of things
that you would use TensorFlow
or those types of tools.
This is a model that can detect
buildings and structures.
And last fall, there
were some hurricanes that
were heading toward Florida.
And so we were saying,
well, could we actually
scale this model across
the whole state of Florida?
So that took us a couple hours.
And that's across hundreds
of terabytes of data.
So why might you also
want to use or know
about where all the
buildings are being produced?
Well, construction
takes raw materials.
And those correlate into
commodities and demand
structures.
So in this case, steel.
And again, this is just things
that weren't really visible
or weren't very easy to measure
without tremendous amounts
of computing power and
that massive data that's
being collected.
Water, already talked about
that a bit once before.
This is a different modality.
We're sending a radar
signal down to the earth.
It bounces off the
earth's surface.
It gives us almost a
height measurement.
You can see heights in
reservoirs and areas like that.
You think about how many
areas water is an input
to the pattern of life.
So that's everything
from food and food supply
and the types of
models we build there.
And those of us
that live in places
like the West, western half of
the US, New Mexico, California,
we know how volatile
a water supply can be.
Once you know about buildings,
you might care about trees,
or encroachment of trees.
Looking down and
being able to identify
a tree versus vegetation
is actually really hard.
They both look like
vegetation that's growing.
There's photosynthesis
occurring.
You can see both
of them the same.
This is the place where
we are able to take LIDAR
to train and see the height, and
then be able to differentiate
and apply this to places where
we didn't have LIDAR coverage,
and basically run this
over the whole globe.
And again, you think
about last summer
out here in California, look at
some of the devastating fires.
We were able to scale
and run this model
and map out every single tree in
the entire state of California.
So that's just-- it took
lots and lots of computing
horsepower and lots of storage.
But these are just a
couple quick examples.
And I really show
them just to point out
how wide the use cases are,
how varying the datasets are.
Now think how different the
code and the models have to be.
There's not just a magic
model and there's not
a magic dataset.
So when our customers are
building these types of models,
what are they coming
to us and asking for?
Well, they care deeply
about the physical world.
A lot of them are
Fortune 500 companies.
They care about
physical infrastructure.
But a lot of them are very
concerned about security
as well.
We all are.
And often, they're
wanting to train a model,
so make their own intellectual
property off their data, which
is their intellectual property.
And they want to know
that their model is
isolated from other customers,
and it's safe and secure.
And so we want to enable them
to be able to build and train
and test those models about
all of our petabytes of data--
so it kind of has to
live next to the data--
and know that the
security isolation
isn't going to slow down or
cause delays in the training.
And then they want
to have confidence
that they'll be able to--
that other users of
the system aren't
going to be able to
access their data
or their intellectual property.
So what challenges
do we have when
trying to build that
type of a platform?
Well, each model is
executing someone else--
one of our user's
machine learning code.
So we need to be able to execute
that securely and at scale.
Each model has very
different requirements.
Some of these models
are very CPU intensive.
Others are very
memory intensive.
Maybe some of them
need to use a GPU.
These are pretty big in scale.
I'll come in most
mornings and I don't
see 10 or 20 cores running
on our [? graphonograph. ?]
I see tens of thousands
of CPU cores that
are running, that somebody
is going out and building
models or testing models
against those data sets.
So it needs to scale
and be efficient.
And we thought
originally of doing this
through isolating
with GKE node pools
and making one node
pool per customer.
But that runs into
a lot of limitations
once you start getting
a few customers.
We thought of using a
cluster, a whole Kubernetes
cluster per customer.
That also runs into
a lot of limitations.
And we wanted to do
this-- we're a startup.
We don't have just
infinite resources.
Most of you don't either.
And so we're trying to do this
as efficiently as possible
from a cost perspective and
still get that security.
So we wanted to leverage
Kubernetes scheduler
to get that really
tight bin packing.
So on GCP, there's a lot of
great tools for data and things
like data exfiltration.
We leverage things like
VPC service controls
to prevent data exfiltration.
But for models and
model execution,
we need to execute
that user's code.
So the first thing
we do is we carve out
a user namespace for each user.
And then we restrict
what they can talk to.
They cannot talk to the
Kubernetes control plane under
the hood.
They can only talk to
our Descartes Labs APIs.
So that's a really
important separation.
And then our Descartes Labs APIs
are talking to the Kubernetes
control plane.
And that's how we're scaling
up and down the workloads.
And then for our
Descartes Labs APIs
to get visibility
into what's going on,
to be able to do things
like rate limiting
or security telemetry, that's
all handled through Istio.
Our user workloads,
as Ian just showed,
those go in a GKE
Sandbox node pool.
And so as it's been
mentioned, that
improves a lot with security.
It limits assist
calls to the kernel.
It separates each user.
And it's a lot more efficient
than making a node pool
for every single customer.
For us, we get much
improved on the cost side.
We run most of our workloads
on things like preemptable VMs.
So that's critical to be
able to use that and make
that efficient in
terms of pricing.
And we get the tighter bin
packing of those workloads
and then still
improve isolation.
So how did we
enable GKE Sandbox?
As was mentioned, you
basically set the sandbox type
to gVisor when you do
a node pool creation.
And what's really great was
we didn't change our code.
We didn't have to have our
users change their code
to get this degree of isolation.
And we could run this
on an existing cluster.
We simply just made
a new node pool.
So it's very easy to get
this started and just start
testing your workloads
and see how they do.
So the next question
you might say
is, well, how did
it actually perform
for these types of machine
learning workloads?
The basic test case--
we've only tested this
on a few workloads.
But the startup cost is
around about a second.
And we're running models
in minutes to hours today.
So we can live with a second.
And then those rough models
are about 1% difference
in terms of overall performance.
So to be honest, I would
say that's within the margin
of error in our measurements.
So that's more than adequate.
And so this is now
available, and we're
making this available to
all of our customers today.
With that, I'll
hand it to Yoshi.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank
you so much, Tim.
It's great to see this is
not like a demonstration.
It's running in your real,
real system, seeing the value.
So as Tim quickly
touched, I'm going
to dig a little bit
deeper on the performance
to set the tone correct.
GKE Sandbox is about
boosting your performance.
It's all about
providing isolation.
And providing that
sort of isolation
and [? national ?]
defense, we're
going to take some cycles
from your workflows
and give back this
defense with ease,
and which will lead
to the cost efficiency
that Tim just described.
So for machine learning
workloads, like Tim introduced,
yes, these are some--
this is a kind of data
from the machine learning
inference workflows
or a prediction.
And these types of CPU and
memory oriented workloads,
the cycles that we need
to provide to give you
back the isolation
that Tim talked about,
are roughly about 2% to
3% of [? overhead. ?]
So if you're wondering,
like the workloads,
like you have similar
workloads like Tim's, this
should be a very good fit for
you, because with just only 2%
of a cycle, you get these
kind of benefit upfront.
Now, workloads like Redis,
I think a lot of you
may know about Redis.
It's in-memory data store,
one of the most popular
staple workloads on GKE.
These type of workflows need
20% to 30% of cycles from you
to return to benefit.
But if you have SaaS
and multi-tenancy,
for example, if you have Redis
instance for each customer
where today you create
a different cluster,
or nodes even, then GKE
Sandbox should still
be able to help you greatly to
provide you this bin packing
capability with ease.
Lastly, I'm going to
show about the FFmpeg
and then Wordpress use case.
So FFmpeg is a well-known
transcoding open source
program.
And Wordpress, as
Ian already showed,
is a blog and web
hosting platform.
They are actually both network
and file oriented workflows.
However, the way they do the
I/O are actually different.
Compared to WordPress, which
will issue I/O one by one,
FFmpeg actually gathers
I/O very nice way,
so that GKE Sandbox
doesn't have to take
too many cycles from you.
It's only about 5% to actually--
5% is pretty much
the cycles that we
need to give you back
this isolation, which will
lead to the cost efficiency.
So if you're
wondering, OK, I'm now
interested in a GKE
Sandbox, but which workflows
will be the great fit,
actually, this few [? higher ?]
number I/Os should be
a very good guideline
to find workflows that will be
very, very beneficial by using
GKE Sandbox.
Just wrapping up then.
So we introduced GKE Sandbox.
This will be publicly
available in late April.
All the things are queued
up waiting for after Next
to unlock everything.
GKE Sandbox will provide defense
in-depth to your Kubernetes pod
with ease.
No application changes.
Like two lines,
which Tim showed,
is exactly what you have to do.
It will be great for
a team interested
in SaaS and multi-tenancy.
And it's based on open source
gVisor, which Ian talked about.
And we put a lot of effort into
providing better experience
as product.
All you have to do is to just,
in turn, create a node pool,
and turn it on in your pod spec.
Rest of the things will
happen behind the scene.
And we also added, actually,
a lot of optimization
around performance.
So if you're wondering
which workloads
to use for GKE Sandbox,
please look at the numbers
that I kind of shared today.
That's [? pretty much ?] it.
Thank you very
much for listening.
If you have any questions,
please come-- we only
have less than a minute.
More than happy to take
your questions offline.
So feel free to come
to [? hit us. ?]
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]